when daria was five months pregnant she
felt dangerously ill with the bacterial
infection listeria she was filled with
fear told there was a strong chance
she'd lose her baby
but it was after luke was born that she
really struggled i felt very very low
and
apart from a handful of very close
people to me
i kept getting
answers such as you know you should feel
grateful
your son is alive his son is well just
basically needed some reassurance
that
you know i'm actually going to be fine
and that i was not alone
she was given antidepressants and
directed towards an online self-help
program but felt the depth of her
depression was dismissed
and daria isn't alone
the mental health charity pandas which
provide support during the perinatal
period covering pregnancy and the first
year post-childbirth
says thousands of struggling parents are
not getting adequate help from the nhs
when asked about their experiences more
than a quarter of those seeking support
said they felt their concerns were not
taken seriously
two in five said they had to wait too
long to receive help and three quarters
said their condition got worse in that
time
hovid hasn't helped putting immense
pressure on the nhs
it means demand for the charities
services is 70 higher than before the
pandemic lots of parents plan on having
a baby and they have a key
kind of
vision of what that would look like but
due to lockdown restrictions
and the pandemic itself
that journey has been very very
different the government says community
perinatal health services have been
rolled out countrywide with more than 40
000 women seen last year
but daria believes too many are still
being left to cope alone
now she volunteers for the charity that
helped her when she needed it most
emma birchley sky muse south london